hey everyone today we are going to talk
about the mind-blowing technology which
is revolutionizing the present and the
future that is none other than immersive
technologies immersive technologies
comprising of virtual reality augmented
reality and mixed reality are amongst
the fastest growing and fascinating
technologies to do so what is immersive
technology to put it in a nutshell
immersive technologies create or extend
reality and this is done by immersing
the user in a digital environment having
applications in different domains this
technology is gaining momentum with
every passing day and are transforming
and helping us reimagine the future
let's start with virtual reality virtual
reality uses we are headsets to create a
simulator environment and helps an
individual to immerse into it to
experience an entirely different reality
however the historical journey of
virtual reality began back in the
eighteen hundreds this marvelous idea
has been evolving from the time
practical photography came into
existence
modern highlake invented the first VR
device called sensorama in 1957 his
multimedia device the sensorama
is considered one of the earliest VR
systems however the term virtual reality
was coined later by Jaron Lanier in 1987
during his intense research on this
evolving technology a lot of companies
are investing billions of dollars in the
VR sector some of the best via products
are oculus quest Nintendo LeBeau VR kit
Sony PlayStation VR Lenovo Mirage and
many more these gadgets enable an
individual to immerse in a digital
environment to experience a world which
is different from reality you might
think we are is all about gaming isn't
it but the potential of VR doesn't stop
there it is revolutionizing many other
industries like education military
medicine and sports to name a few here
are some examples of VR in real life
class VR is an innovative new concept in
the educational industry which uses we
are tech to raise the engagement and
knowledge retention for students of all
ages class vr uses VR headsets with a
user-friendly interface for both
students and teachers gesture controls
and
very educational resources Facebook is
coming up with a new idea called
Facebook horizon which is an ever
expanding via community where you can
explore clay and create it helps you to
defy physics and reality and experience
that impossible and we also have BR 316
which is a 360-degree audio-visual
simulation it allows the user to look
around in any direction just like how
they look and observe things in real
life you can experience anything from
standing on top of a pyramid to enjoying
Tomorrowland sitting at home
isn't that wonderful we can't end the
topic if we didn't highlight the role of
VR in gaming a great take on this is the
movie ready player one by Steven
Spielberg the film is set in the year
2045 when the world is on the brink of
chaos and collapse but humans have our
salvation in a virtual reality universe
where they could make the impossible
possible let's hear what Stephen himself
feels about the we our universe you know
world that we would someday be able to
escape into you know a world that you
know we leave our world but we don't
leave our world we don't have to walk
five feet to leave our world we just had
to put something over our eyes and we
are suddenly thrust into a wonderful
world of someone's imagination next up
is a our augmented reality is a
technology that projects
computer-generated augmentations on top
of reality helping us perform tasks
better and efficiently AR which falls in
between reality and virtual reality is a
method used to render real-world data
and present it intuitively so that
virtual elements resemble the present
reality to an extent the revolution
doesn't stop here have you ever tried to
catch Pokemon using Pokemon go or fit
any furniture using the ikea app these
are made possible by the technology
called augmented reality augmented
reality has seen raging in popularity
over the past few years and the
revolution is not stopping anytime soon
AR is giving brands the power to provide
their customers with unique experiences
that can prove to be the difference
between purchase and dropout let's have
a quick look at the history of AR so you
might think AR is a new tech
and she well on the contrary it has been
around for numerous decades
I'm Sutherland developed the first air
gadget called SWAT of Damocles during
1968 this system used computer graphics
to show users simple wireframe drawings
from Pokemon go to training future
surgeons augmented reality is starting
to infiltrate many industries of our
society today but what exactly is
augmented reality looking into the most
popular applications of AR first up we
have location-based AR apps like Google
Maps which please digital directions on
top of the real world and shows you
where to walk next we have Google lens
it is another application that enhances
the search experience with google lens
you don't have to type your query any
more just open the app and aim it at
what you want to learn about google lens
will identify the object and give you
all the essential details about it
then we have the snapchat filters these
are one of the best examples of AR and
as you know snapchat has become a trend
among the younger generations did you
know that mysterio couldn't have fooled
spider-man without his CR technology but
thanks to his fight ascent Spidey dodged
all the drones destroyed them all and
gave us a good ending even Facebook has
plans to build a our glasses to create
3d maps of the world if you are still
skeptical about AR check out what Mark
Zuckerberg has to speak about AR so
that's why I'm so excited about
augmented reality because it's gonna
make it so that we can create all kinds
of things that until today have only
been possible in the digital world and
we're gonna be able to interact with
them and explore them together next in
this line of immersive technologies as M
are a virtual reality and augmented
reality impressed you get ready for the
best of both worlds that is mixed
reality em are mixed reality is all
about blending the real world with
virtual reality
unlike augmented reality users can
interact with virtual objects and mixed
reality what was nearly impossible a few
years ago and was limited to our
imagination like interacting with your
favorite Marvel superhero is now
because of Mr technology does it seem
similar to we are well you can call it
AR 2.2 mr is still in its early stage
and it'll take a wife order to reach the
consumers however the investment in M R
and AR is expected to reach four billion
dollars by this year and the future of M
R is not so distant a Mars application
aren't fast and its main uses are in the
field of education training sports
health care space missions and even
construction don't many use cases are in
the testing phase this idea isn't
far-fetched by any means the best
example of M R is the microsoft hololens
which is just a pair of mr smart glasses
it allows you to experience 3d holograms
that melt seamlessly into the real
environment you can interact with those
augmentations using your bare hands and
get all the information you need let's
now hear what Alex kipman the designer
behind the hololens thinks about mixed
reality in the real world we're finding
great success in mixed reality from
education to health care to
manufacturing which is what you see a
lot of the cases happening here here's a
quick recap of what we know so far so
augmented reality adds digital elements
to a live environment whereas virtual
reality implies a complete immersive
experience that shuts out the physical
world on the other hand a mixed reality
experience combines elements of both AR
and VR where you can interact with both
the real world and the digital elements
immersive technologies are quickly
becoming a part of our daily lives and
they are here to stay not only enhancing
human experiences but helping brands
market their products effectively and
successfully to attract their target
audiences from gaming to buying
furniture immersive technologies are
taking the world by storm so what do you
think is next comment your ideas in the
comment section below and stay tuned for
more from simply
you
[Music]